hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about
what i consider to be three of the
biggest myths about learning any
language
number one that you have to
practice speaking and focus on grammar
number two
that you have to go to school
and number three that it's difficult
and i'm gonna do this with reference to
some information that i got from steven
crash krashen i'm still
excited about about having had lunch
with stephen krashen in riverside
california
uh last week and at that time he gave me
a paper
where which is called can second
language requires acquirers rather reach
high levels of proficiency through
self-selected
reading
and in this paper he confirms
that the more we read
the better we learn and the higher our
score on
tests like toeic and there is research
to show
how many hours
of reading will give you what result on
toeic and i'm going to analyze this in
more detail in a blog post at my blog
in doing research for this
because this
uh paper is uh was produced by stephen
krashen and by beniko mason
who is an english teacher in japan
i also googled beniko mason and here
there's a very interesting paper called
self-selected pleasure reading and story
listening for foreign foreign language
classrooms
and both these papers stress the basic
fact that in order to
acquire a language
more than anything else you need to read
and it identifies how much you need to
read
and of course listening is also powerful
i happen to be a great fan of listening
because it helps prepare me to speak
because it's something i can do
while doing other tasks but i know that
i need a lot of reading in order to
acquire vocabulary and there's a number
of gems in both of these articles
about how
you know at the early stages most
learners of language never get past the
beginning beginner or early intermediate
stage so whether those people speak
absolutely correctly whether we hound
them on points of grammar that in any
case are going to take a lot of exposure
and practice
before it's going to click in maybe the
main thing is to get those people to
where they can communicate a little bit
without worrying about how correctly
they speak
and that's just one example there are
many more and this is so fundamental so
important
read and listen and therefore
you don't need to be instructed you
don't need to be corrected i mean once
you get to an intermediate level
the other goal of language teaching
should be to make you an autonomous
independent learner so once you reach
that intermediate level through lots of
reading and listening you will more and
more correct yourself or you'll seek out
some grammar explanations or whatever
wherever you feel that there are gaps or
mistakes that you keep making you'll
start to notice those if you are
an autonomous and motivated learner but
to get you to that stage rather than
overwhelming you with rules
and we can get people to choose things
of interest stories whatever they're
interested in to read and listen i know
i sound like a bit of a broken record
but it's so overwhelmingly true
and not everybody likes to read when
they don't know the words and and
basically that's what's behind link i
was the same way i had all kinds of
books in different languages there were
too many words that i didn't know i
didn't like looking them up in a
dictionary so therefore we developed
link as a sort of an assist but the
fundamental activity is reading and
listening and that will get you to where
you have a sufficient base in the
language so that you can then work on
the areas that you're weak in including
pronunciation but at least you have a
feel for the language you have some
vocabulary you're not discouraged so the
three again the three major mistakes
that people make they think they need
lots of instruction they got to worry
about grammar they got to worry about
output not true second of all that they
need to go to a classroom they don't it
can help if you don't have the
motivation but it's not necessarily
necessary and the third thing is that
it's complicated it's not complicated it
requires
time
and motivation
so there you go i kind of say the same
thing over and over again but it's so
important and so few people really grasp
it so for further information please
visit my blog i'll be putting a post up
there within the next week or so thanks
for listening bye for now